wait a minute wait a minute we can
one-up it why don't we take him tomorrow
Lago
we can and by the way why don't you tell
them what happened when you and your
husband met Trump what did he do with
Melania that's that's a good story it's
really an incredible I'll try to do this
somewhat quick version of it we go it
was the week of impeachment yeah there
was 18 impeachments I was like which one
dude yeah the first the first Shaman the
original and remember remember those two
weeks where everybody everyone in
mainstream media the walls are closing
in Trump is freaking out so Mueller's
got him the whole thing so I heard I was
at a turning point USA thing in West
Palm I I spoke and then then Trump
announced that he was coming so they
cleared out all these so basically I
ended up opening for him and then for
Trump he spoke yeah dude but it wasn't
planned that way it was just that he
announced that he was coming out of
nowhere so then so I spoke he speaks I
had never heard him speak in person
before and first so already something
had moved with me that morning because
when he spoke and you see him speak live
and then you read the media after you
can really see the disconnect so there
was a beautiful moment in his speech
where he's talking about wind power and
he's like I know win power more than
anybody and nobody knows more about win
than me and the Turbo and he's going on
and it's so obviously a joke it's so
obviously just a punk and I turned to
David and I said to him I guarantee you
Politico is going to write a headline or
one that Donald Trump says he knows more
about wind and of course five minutes
later the headline shows up anyway uh we
see Junior there and we become sort of
friendly he says you want to come to
dinner with Kimberly and I to Mar-A-Lago
tonight so obviously we said yes we go
in again this is the height of
impeachment we're in the you know
there's two rooms there we're in the
smaller rooms there's only about 20
people or so there's Trump sitting there
with Melania and Rudy Giuliani and one
or two other people and he has his shirt
open really open no tie so first yeah so
first up you never see Trump like this
right his jackets kind of lean in back
he looks relaxed eat his hair looked
relaxed like he's just and he's laughing
and having a blast and I'm just you know
we're not sitting at the same table but
I just kind of have my you know I'm just
looking right
anyway at the end of dinner Junior says
hey you want to meet my dad so obviously
yeah I'd love to meet your dad so we we
walk over and and the president's
sitting and he says Dad I want you to
meet Dave Rubin
um and and he looks at me and he's kind
of he's sitting so he looks up and he's
like I kind of recognize you I kind of
and I was like oh well I'm on Tucker a
lot or maybe you see me outside because
oh yeah yeah that must be it and then he
turns to David my husband and he goes
well who are you and he goes well I'm
his husband and he he goes husband
husband
that's great you guys are gay he goes
Melania can you believe it these two
guys are gay
he goes he goes guys let me tell you
something you know what your only
problem is you're too handsome both of
you guys are too handsome yeah that's
what he said and then Melania then uh
she's kind of points she's with a friend
she's kind of pointing at David so David
walks around the table to talk to
Melania and then it's me Junior and
Trump and then somebody grab Junior so
now it's just me and Trump and this is
also so it's impeachment and it's also
right when Bloomberg got in the race
yeah so I had this moment alone with
Trump I'm like I got to say something
that says you know something so I was
like I was like Mr President I just got
to tell you my crazy Theory and my
theory is that the machine wants Biden
because it's just a Vestige of the old
thing but they know he can't survive in
the debates because he's so bad so so
Bloomberg is in basically as a decoy
which I really believe is what happened
they threw him in it was never real but
they needed because Biden was still
leading they needed all the energy
remember those two debates with
Bloomberg it was only about him Biden
barely spoke because they knew he would
break down under under attacks
so I tell him this I said it's a
complete decoy Bloomberg's not running
it's all about Biden and he's he's like
this he's like you know that's that's
something that's something and then he
goes and this also really changed me on
Trump he reaches across the table and he
puts his hand on Melania like very
gingerly softly puts his hand on Melania
and he goes honey honey listen to this
and he said it lovingly right and the
the meme is that they hate each other or
she's a cat you know kept she slapped
what happened at one time they played it
a million times I'm telling you he did
it in the way a husband that loves his
wife would touch her hand and then he
called her honey so the way he did that
so he has me repeat what I said to him
uh to her and I say it and she kind of
nods and then he goes nah he just hates
me talking about Bloomberg meaning
that's why he got it he just hates me
but the thing that moved me more than
the gay thing or that silly story is
that he loves his wife it was very
obvious that I told him something
interesting and his first inclination
was to tell us to tell his wife what
does that tell us about the guy very
interesting very interesting yeah I've
I've heard him a few times at Mar-A-Lago
and I got to tell you the guy could have
been a comedian he's a stand-up he's a
stand-up
and because there's no cameras he gets
up and it's 90 minutes no script no
nothing any half the time you're
laughing with jokes and obviously he's
trolling I think he's gonna go all the
time as the greatest troller of all time
I think he has the gold medal for it I
think he owes the Guinness Book of World
Record for it I don't think anyone's
going to come close to him as a Troll
he's in the league of his own but what's
so impressive about the whole situation
is the fact that he's about to get
impeached a second time Biden could
potentially win and he's just having a
good time I'm telling you see this guy
yeah shirt open like this there was
something it was just like he he that
also was when I was just like all of
media it broke down a lot of things for
me that he loves his wife he didn't care
about gays that the media is just so
dishonest it wasn't just the wind power
article that I knew was going to come it
was just he's freaking out you know he's
in his inner sanctum with his and it was
like no he isn't he's sitting there
laughing his ass off they just lie about
it they really they really don't like
this guy too much they really don't like
this guy too much
but here's here's going back to it
here's the thing the bench is deep on
the right the bench is not deep on the
left even if I ask you right now who you
couldn't come up with five names on the
left Booker not gonna happen no Pete
Beto who do you got no they'll make it
they'll make a BP that's the one that
they'll move on don't make it be Pete
yeah don't forget about Gavin Gavin is
going to be there there's no question is
going to be there Gavin's going to be
there no question do you have any stars
you're excited about outside of mansion
because he's not going to run he's not
going to run Cinema's not going to run
and you don't think Mansion would run if
a mansion ran he would never get the
support from the left Tulsi Gafford
would never get the support from the
left so because you need to Rally your
base right and who's the Democratic base
right now it's a lot of the AOC crowd
the Bernie crowd but that's not who the
true Democratic voter is like the the
loudest people in the room the 10 on
that side just like the do you like that
do you like Tulsi I'm guessing you
probably like yeah I mean I don't follow
her well enough to be like that's my
girl yeah uh but yeah I do like the fact
that she challenges The Establishment
yeah she's she's a good woman we've
become friendly she's a good woman I
can't I I mean I say this to her
privately all the time but it's like how
are you a Democrat still it just doesn't
yeah what is she moving to Florida by
the way I mean uh well she's in Hawaii
she loves Hawaii she loves the ways yeah
oh yeah we go back and forth we are uh
uh her flight is a long flight we're
trying to get a date for her to get on
the podcast the next time she's in crazy
idea crazy idea okay we go to Hawaii we
go to Hawaii we do the show you're
willing to take it on the road you got
you got great people around you they're
willing to go to Hawaii for you man if
you go you go you go an interview
hour flight what is what is it you want
to send me to Hawaii
that'd be great but what did she say
when you question her about being a
Democrat I don't want to say anything
that we've talked about privately but
you know I I think I can say it's
obvious from her public statements that
she's hanging on by a thread that that
she's trying to hold the position that I
think is an honorable position that
they're not all insane and that there
could be a decent liberal left I think
that's what you're trying to say you are
or at least were and it just and trust
me I'm a guy that my first book was all
it was a defense of liberalism it's just
it doesn't work anymore Trump you know I
kept making the argument and trust me it
was not easy to come out as a trump
supporter or it's just a stupid
statement a trump supporter I voted for
Trump yes I voted for a guy who's
President
um I was making the argument for a long
time that Trump actually was defending
liberalism and conservatism it was
obvious how he was defending
conservatism he believed in the free
market he was appointing conservative
judges things like that obviously but he
was defending liberalism because look
the guy he had a freaking rainbow
flag on stage with him before he was
president he was actually defending
equality remember that moment at the
State of the Union I'm sure you guys saw
it when he talked about all uh was it
all-time low Black and Hispanic
unemployment and the entire
Congressional Black Caucus sat there
like this and didn't applaud he did not
care about any of those things he was
actually trying to save both you're
never going to get a more liberal
conservative real that's really the
truth he doesn't care remember his
answer on the trans bathroom thing they
said to him uh what do you think about
trans bathrooms when that was a big
thing he goes I'm a builder if you tell
me I could build a hotel with one
bathroom you know how much I'm Gonna
Save I would freaking love to do that
that's the right answer that's the right
answer but they said he's a transpho but
he hates gays and he hates what is going
on with the whole trans thing these days
I don't know so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]